oh hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're the slomo
guys a while ago Destin from smarter
every day we're all tired made an
amazing video about Tattooing in slow-mo
you can check out the video right there
and I thought because we've got some new
macro equipment it might be cool to
revisit that video and see below the
skin or under the skin through the skin
by tattooing some ballistic gel off cuts
also because neither of us are actually
brave enough to get the tattoo ourselves
very true okay to start I think we
should just see the tattoo gun on its
own to see the needles come out Ultra
macro about five times magnification
here I wonder if every time you go for a
tattoo how many people you would
discourage from getting a tattoo if you
showed them this first I think this is
going to look horrendous have a look at
this Frame
that is ultra macro
go
oh I think they go out of frame what
oh wow
that's good Miss Me So how many needles
are on this I thought there was just one
but actually it looks like what four
really close together needles to like
this is a what the lining so you're
supposed to create a line with this one
it's jobbling around all over the place
let's see it's in I'm nine and it's back
on four to five yeah five to six
milliseconds per cycle flip that is
rapid something moving that quick is
just insane isn't it I've never seen a
plastic end on a tattoo gun well I think
the tattoo guns you go to when you do it
you know professionally they reuse the
not the 70 ones on Amazon yeah no no
these are just plastic nibbed Bad Boys
plastic nibbed jobblers go for it
yep that is so immensely small can you
put something in for scale like your
finger or something yeah see like that
is how damn small those needles are oh
it looks like something from Alien you
know like it's like the xenomorph second
mouse yeah that's it oh that's
horrendous okay I guess I wasn't
expecting the surface tension of the ink
to completely cover the needles like you
can't see them individually anymore no
God this must have taken ages before
electricity
okay here's our little sliver of
ballistic gel mimicking uh someone's arm
yes it definitely armed 20 000 FPS
oh man that looks so deep doesn't it is
that too deep it's supposed to be one
and a half mil deep so it gets through
the dermis of the skin and deposits the
ink underneath it goes much further than
it puts ink or is it going to start
leaving trails living I think it's going
to start leaving trails of ink the gel
does actually kind of Ripple just like
the skin does as well yeah oh yeah look
it's leaving like streaks of ink yeah
does that mean under every tattoo is
little spikes of ink like that must do
like it just the skin just grabs it like
the needles pull it through capillary
action and then the skin just grabs it
and it stays there under the skin I mean
obviously ballistic gel isn't skin but
yeah to get the same effect you know
it's as close as we can get look at the
Ripple when it pops out look at the
there the surface of the skin just you
can actually see look you can actually
see where the the top layer of skin is
like around the needle and then it
starts like sliding back up the needle
as it goes in like that's like the area
where it pierced and it's sort of
dragging that down but then you can see
it's sliding and leaving a trail of ink
there you can also get ones that are
like a bunch all in a row for creating
like shading
should we see one of those next yeah oh
and you're like poking the uh what is it
really hard like smushing it into this
you might be doing that a bit too hard
that's going really deep you might be
just millering this
don't get a tattoo by me okay okay this
so this is my maybe not
completely accurate
from this close up you can actually see
the needle pushing in and the surface of
the skin sliding up the needle it's
almost cleaning the ink off the needle
which leaves a pool of Ink on the
surface of the skin and then as soon as
the needle pops out it sucks the ink
down the hole that it left it almost
like it's almost as though there's no
ink in there until the needle pops out
and then ink rushes down the wound
Channel that's wild like each individual
one is an individual sort of wound where
it's the positive ink they've done our
lines on our ballistic gel a poor
ballistic gel now we're going to do a
little bit of shading in red lipstick
red different type of needle yeah
different Arrangement different
Arrangement instead of sort of lots of
tiny needles all in one spot doing this
they're going to be four or five sorry
fatter needles in a line to create like
a coloring in basically I'm going to see
what it looks like coming straight
towards the macro lens might be quite
hard to see what's going on because I
think focus is maybe a third of a
millimeter laughs
yep
oh oh wow I see it like going pinch off
I can see what it is now before I
couldn't yeah
weird it's like you know uh the keyhole
surgery
and we're entering the left ventricle oh
yeah you would just have no idea what
that is would you
that's what that's what your skin sees
when it looks up it looks like that
could be anything you could be like oh
that's the um yeah that's a vein in an
owl's Eye I'd be like okay
10 different things
if someone 10 guesses and they probably
wouldn't get what it was
they thought that the shading needles
were in a straight line but they're kind
of like staggered yeah they're staggered
two and three yeah so you're gonna put a
little bit of skin there yeah okay and
I'm gonna set the focus
not on the needles but on sort of the
underside of the skin okay okay go for
it here we go
[Music]
all right I think I've tattooed that
spot pretty well oh yeah you've reamed
that area it's like under the skin
looking up but it's got the texture of
skin somehow you like one of those fish
that live underwater that have a
see-through head like
there we go oh
so the needle's gonna come out of focus
but I've kept the focus on the basically
underside of the skin sure okay
jiggly thing is just jiggling look at
all this all those bikes you see all the
little pricks of color and then each one
of those will have like a little string
of uh of tattooing along yeah and
obviously As you move that along the
skin it will get that's how you get your
shading
that's saying isn't it all those little
tiny puncture marks that's I I think I
just didn't realize how deep it went
obviously it's only like a mil and a
half and we're seeing it massively
enlarged but it's still pretty Savage
isn't it it is Savage like that to me
doesn't look Pleasant
we're doing it also in the same exact
spot yeah yeah over and over because the
gel isn't skin it doesn't have the same
qualities of of keeping the ink in like
yeah it you know the to get the same
effect of the ink it has to go slightly
deeper yeah this is just like a rough
estimation but I think it's it really is
definitely illustrating something like
there's definitely a visual there that
I've never thought about yeah
let's have a look at the cross section
of your handiwork oh it's so tiny it
looks Savage on the slow man it looks
huge it's only gone in that far yeah
a small Interruption now for the sponsor
of this video Laura Laura is a brand of
lenses that I've used many times over
the years on this channel they make the
famous Pro Blends which is one of my
favorite lenses here's all the times
we've used it as of today they've just
released the pro tube set it's a set of
three lenses firstly all three lenses
are now T8 instead of 14 each with
slightly different functionality there's
a direct view classic probe the next one
has the end of the probe tilted at 35
degrees which we used in this video to
look slightly up on the subject and
avoid getting the Shadow from the top of
the probe encroaching onto the image and
what I feel is the most interesting one
is the Periscope they did previously
release a periscopic lens called the
periprobe the downside to that in my
opinion was that you couldn't put that
camera on a tripod and look straight
down into like a tank you had to suspend
the camera above with this you can
actually have the camera on a tripod
outside the tank but the end of the lens
inside the tank so stay on the lookout
for that video If you want to get your
hands on any of these lenses make sure
to check the link in the description and
just so you know it is an affiliate link
I'm always very excited when a brand
I've used multiple times in the past
reaches out and offers to sponsor a
video so big old thanks to Lauer for
offering to sponsor this one and sending
over these lenses
that's quite nice isn't it it's pretty
nice looks good I don't know if that's
put me off having a tattoo even more or
whether I now want one well I already
wasn't going to get that tattoo I talked
about before but I'm definitely not
going to get it now
also because neither of us are actually
brave enough to get the tattoo ourselves
very true
I don't have any I think I would get one
I just don't know what I put yeah I um
I'm glad I didn't get what I thought
would be cool a few years ago what was
that a few things
[Laughter]
but you're too embarrassed
you'd have to say it do you want to say
it
well you know like
sorry the video have to wait just a sec
you know like um I used to be working
out and stuff when I was in the Army
yeah and uh
you know how The Rock has like like a
tattoo here yeah like a chest one like
that and it goes down his arm I thought
it'd be quite cool to get something like
that
just know it's not like a Samoan yeah
well that pattern is yeah but like I
wasn't gonna get that but I thought it
was something similar like where it's
like a Peck and all that then I got fat
I'm so glad I didn't get that
I have a newfound respect for everyone
who sat through
insane tattoo sessions like full body
I've lost that I dropped it
a lot bouncy yeah it's not quite the
same is it yeah 10 10 obviously I'm
brave enough to try and drop in off Tony
Hawk's half pipe 15 foot up break my arm
but yeah I think that that has made me
too much of a chicken to actually get a
tattoo I think I'm right with you there
well hopefully you enjoyed that video or
you found it disturbing I think either
emotion is fine here on YouTube make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
and we'll see you in the next one
thanks for watching